the number of coronavirus cases around
the world is approaching a million the
United States is worst hit with more
than 200,000 infections and the death
toll has risen by a record 884 in the
last day alone worst hit New York City
the epicenter of America's coronavirus
outbreak the streets of New York are
deserted
but ambulances are a constant presence
on the streets the state's death toll
has doubled in just three days a
refrigerated truck was brought in to
help this Brooklyn Hospital deal with a
sharp rise in fatalities hospitals are
running out of medications some
hospitals don't have protective gear for
staff or family members of patients that
come to the hospital we're running out
of medications we're running out of
equipment and we're even running out of
oxygen which is something that patient
that have closed in 19 to 2 hundred and
forty thousand lives across the country
despite this the pandemic authorities
are urging restraint if you got are
gonna wear a face covering when you go
out please understand you still don't
need an n95 mask and if you take one of
those in 95 masks you may be taking it
out of the hands of a health care worker
who desperately needs it to care for
patients union leaders are warning that
frontline health care workers are at
risk you're here to say that our members
are afraid to go to work because safety
protocols aren't keeping them safe that
is what I were calling for hazard pay
you're trying to keep ourselves safe we
are trying to keep our co-workers safe
we are trying to keep our community safe
health care workers who didn't get
access to a mosque are now stuck at home
so I haven't really been given too much
direction besides just wait it out stay
home keep yourself quarantined and wait
it out and if you get worse you know if
you you can't breathe or you know your
few start having raging fevers on I want
one
President Trump is warning Americans
they face a very tough and painful two
weeks and he is not given to
understatement well journalists to James
Rennell joined us from New York and gave
us this assessment I think you can say
that the mood in New York City is
becoming increasingly concerned and I
think that goes nationwide as well in
the last 24 hours
there has been a discernible shift in
the emphasis on the scale of this crisis
for example previously President Donald
Trump he was talking about you know the
possibility of there being some cure
being found for coronavirus and perhaps
saying that the crisis wasn't going to
be as long lasting as and wasn't going
to tank the economy for such a long time
now that has changed in the last 24
hours
we've just had President Trump speaking
to the nation again and he said it's
going to be vicious the predictions the
projections for the total death toll
from this crisis that have come out of
the White House suggest that as many as
100,000 or up to 240,000 people could
die and that is even if we start obeying
the social distancing rules and
everybody does they shut up in their
apartments not just here in the
worst-hit part of the country the
tri-state area of New York New Jersey
and Connecticut but in these other parts
of other parts of the country like
Florida and New Orleans that are
starting to show bigger signs of
epidemics there well Dale Fisher chairs
the World Health Organization's global
outbreak alert and research Network he
joins us from Singapore welcome to DW
what do you make of Britain's lack of
testing the one thing that concerns me
is when we say test test test it's about
what you do with that test and the thing
that actually concerns me the most is
when people are found in countries
across the world to be positive they
generally sent home we know that you
know up to 80% of cases are mild and a
lot of em young people and it's very
difficult to
to completely isolate yourself at home
we in the the five countries where where
there is a quite a flat curve and and
relative control we all isolate our
cases in hospital but when that capacity
is is breached then we have community
isolation centers so this is all through
China now Hong Kong Taiwan South Korea
and Singapore so to me it's what you do
with the tests and given that there is
no cure why is testing so important what
exactly if you don't do anything with it
then there's then then you could argue
what's the point in testing the reason
to test is you can identify the cases
and you can take them out of out of
society and you keep them out until and
until they're cleared and then they can
come back in it's not a it's not a
penalty or a punishment to isolate
people isolation as a genuine infection
control intervention to prevent spread
so you can either shut down your whole
community and tell everyone to to self
quarantine or you can pull out the
positive ones isolate them and that that
allows society to function as it is in
in parts of Asia we see TV pictures
every day of people in hazmat suits at
disinfecting the streets as part of a
response to this and this is an approach
that I think you're not necessarily keen
on no I mean maybe it's a community
image that we're taking it seriously I
don't know it's certainly not anything
that we recommend we don't believe
people are catching it from the ground
and and you know it's it makes no sense
it's it's it's quite wrong to spray
people with chlorine I saw images of I
think refugees being sprayed you know
that that's wrong i I think it needs to
be to be stopped I'd rather see images
of of people you know washing their
hands and distancing and things like
that that
that's the community response not not
spraying chlorine everywhere let's have
look to the medium and long term how
should governments avoid a resurgence in
cases in this pandemic and indeed
prepare for the next one I'm not sure
what you mean by the next one if we
would have faced this one first
the you know so many countries or cities
are under lockdown and this lockdown
really needs to be seen as an
opportunity firstly you will stop
transmission if you if you separate
everyone and say don't mix transmission
will eventually burn out there'll be
household clusters and things but it'll
stop you'll also have an opportunity for
your health care system to recover
you'll get your ventilators back you
know people will go one way or the other
though they'll come off the ventilator
hopefully successfully but but but some
will die but your health system can
recover but I think what's most
important is during any lockdown period
is that you reboot your response you
look at your testing you look at what
you're going to do with positive
patients you look at the laws you know
do you have power Public Health powers
to be able to to do what's what's the
right thing for the public how are you
going to do your contact tracing what
are you going to do with with contacts
all these sort of things can now be
debated because you're locked down and
you've got a sort of a breather period
but if you just open up again right
things are the same then it's come back
and history that's important to learn
the lessons good talking to you thank
you for joining us Dale Fisher from the
World Health Organization well here in
Germany I searched for a group of
researchers has turned a hard-hit town
into a study area they're looking at
everything to get information about how
the virus is spread who gets it and what
stops it
this is Germany's wuhan Heinz Beck is
the German epicenter of the corona virus
outbreak now it's about to be turned
into an open-air laboratory
in my spot hoffman has one of the
country's worst affected regions
Hinesburg has reached the point where we
can now see new infections declining
wakandan oi infects so here for the
first time we can ask the question how
many infections went undetected how high
the ratio of those really is who are
sick without ever being diagnosed
doctors are teaming up with pollsters to
analyze a group of 1000 people in the
small community of gangnet following
carnival celebrations in February the
town saw a sudden surge of coronavirus
infections those responsible hope the
mistakes made back then may now produce
some good for others in the end maybe we
won't just be remembered for being the
region where things were really bad
maybe we'll be remembered for handling
the situation well doing as much as we
could it's hope taking samples from all
aspects of daily life will shed some
light on how fast and in which ways the
virus spread Bheema see the problem is
that we are currently relying too much
on mathematical models and if only one
factor turns out to be wrong the whole
calculation model collapses like a house
of cards the team of scientists hopes to
be able to present the first concrete
results on actual infection ratios by
the beginning of next week well here are
some more of the latest developments in
this pandemic the total number of
reported infections worldwide has risen
to almost nine hundred and forty
thousand with more than 47,000 deaths
this year's UN climate summit has been
postponed the cop 26 talk scheduled for
Glasgow in November has been pushed back
to next year and Brazil has reported the
first coronavirus case amongst its
indigenous population a woman from Mika
Karma ethnic group in the Amazon
rainforest has tested positive the
President of the Philippines has ordered
police to shoot dead anyone who causes
trouble in lockdown areas Rodrigo
Duterte stat a televised speech came
just hours after a group of people were
arrested in a manila slum for demanding
the government's do
all to help feed the poor the corona
virus pandemic has plunged the aviation
industry into an unprecedented crisis
airlines have been forced to ground
their fleets as borders are closed and
passenger numbers plummet British
Airways is the latest to take drastic
measures to try and ensure its survival
it's reported to be planning to suspend
about 36,000 staff although the company
has stressed there will be no
redundancies this week being temporarily
halted flights from Gatwick Airport the
UK's second busiest well finance
correspondent Conrad boozin at the
Frankfurt Stock Exchange has more
welcomed Conrad how a market is reacting
to this news good morning Phil well the
shares in International Airlines Group
which is the parent company of British
Airways are up this morning but the
whole sector I can say is pretty stable
this morning on the stock markets all
over Europe no ba of course is not the
only carrier are suffering give us an
overview of the sector would you well of
course this sector was one of the
hardest hit in this crisis it was also
one of the first hit when the corona
epidemic broke out it doesn't even help
that fuel at the moment is super cheap
because of the decline of the oil price
if you don't have passengers to
transport if the amount of cargo is
reduced the way it is right now you
simply don't have to fly you have your
flights grounded it doesn't really help
that fuel is cheap here in Germany the
situation for Lufthansa seems to be
stabilized at the moment 87,000
employees of Lufthansa have entered the
reduced work hours scheme called coats
abide here in Germany that's a scheme
that's supposed to help businesses in
trouble that's when you know the
taxpayer the state takes on the wages of
those workers Lufthansa is also
considering to apply for emergency aid
by the government air france-klm the
French Dutch airline already has applied
for emergency aid so clearly this is
devastating for this particular sector
once we're out of this crisis I'm
presuming that the sector's gonna look
good very different because not every
airlines gonna survive well yes that's a
that's a fair presumption we always
really have seen a couple of casualties
in the UK fly be the regional airline
has gone out of business today it was
reported that the small fleet of Thomas
Cook is going under administration and
we are probably going to see more
businesses you know and it has to be
said general I see it generally the
businesses business models which were
not super sound before the crisis and
which did not have very sound financing
will find it difficult to survive this
crisis Tom Hardy boozing at the
Frankfurt that Stock Exchange thank you
so much well a third of the world's
population is now under some form of
coronavirus lockdown changing life not
just for us but also for our pets
millions of our four-legged friends and
I'm getting extra quality time at home
with their owners and lots of us without
pets and I reconsidering that position
long days stuck at home may be
frustrating for us humans but many of
our four-legged friends have never had
it so good
leo from Florida is lapping up the extra
attention doing this rather tricky time
Leo brings a lot of joy and kisses
we are definitely thoroughly spoiled
because they're not used to seeing us
and being whole day with us
so the turkey 32 spoiled loving that
treats loving spending time with the
foun team in London
Simmons pooch can't believe her luck
everything is gone completely out of the
window as long as social distancing is
practiced there's no reason to give up
walkies and it's not just dogs who are
enjoying more family time
Kweli is usually asleep at this time she
is a night out or night hog but since
all the kids are here and everything we
thought we'd take her out during times
of crisis pets can be a great comfort
that's why across the world animal
adoptions are now soaring we've seen
nearly a 300% increase in adoptions and
interest around foster care applications
and it's been really motivating to see
many people turn to animals for some
companionship over the next few weeks if
not months thanks to the increase in
demand for new furry family members many
of this shelter's cages are now empty
I'll leave you now with a look at some
of the world's normally busy streets and
public spaces silenced by the corona
virus pandemic however the day
[Music]
you
[Music]